I'm James wanna I am speaking from
Bangalore the sign city of media I am
curious to know how simultaneous
discoveries can happen in science does
that mean that two scientists my what
alternately when some Pisco has happened
thank you good question but there is so
many research show in the world that
civil are working on the same duration
some time with different motivations but
on the same projects and it took us
frequently that it is they are obtained
mall as a same time in different
laboratories and for exam this what the
case for example the discovery of giant
magnetoresistance by in the group of
Peter Greenberg and in my group in
France what I can add also it that in
some field is at the candy for example
there is at the time of the discovery of
the I TC superconductor this fellow
research was a very trendy there are
many many research walking in the same
field at the same time and the
probability of similarly discovery is
even larger